the political atmosphere in America  seems so febrile and unpredictable at  the moment  how can the world be sure that America  will deliver on its climate promises  well it looks as if the outcome of the  election is far more favorable to the  Democratic party than most people  expected so I I think there's another  reason for optimism that the policies  established by President Biden and the  Democratic Congress will continue I  think that the  candidates that made themselves  vulnerable to the label extreme are the  ones who appear to have lost and the  ones who have advocated working in a a  cross-partisan bipartisan way are  getting the favor of Voters and I think  that bodes well for the future